[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALLEY RUTZEL: Hi everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
I hope you're having
a great time at Next.
My name is Alley Rutzel
and I'm a senior manager
of user experience at Google.
I work on a new enterprise video
meeting experience in Hangouts,
which are going to be
hearing a little bit more
about tomorrow in the keynote.
So I'm here today to give
you a behind-the-scenes look
into Google's usability
design philosophy,
and how you can apply
what you've learned here
at your organization I will also
be happy to answer questions
at the end of the session,
there will be plenty of time.
I think I timed myself and
this only took 30 minutes.
So, I really do want
to hear from you.
So if you have
questions, please feel
free to ask them at the end.
So first, what exactly do I
mean when I say usability?
A leading expert in the
field defines usability
as a quality attribute
that assesses how easy user
interfaces are to use.
That's pretty
straightforward, but it's also
an oversimplification.
The word usability
can also refer
to methods we employ for
improving ease of use
during the design process.
And I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute.
But for now, let's
talk about usability,
and break it down into what
I consider its six quality
components.
So learnability-- how
easy is it for users
to accomplish basic
tasks the first time
they encounter a design?
The more learnable a system
is, the less time a user
takes in order to understand
how to do a specific task
without having been
previously trained or provided
documentation.
But how important is
learnability in a design?
Think about if you're
designing a user interface
for a kiosk in a mall.
You want people to be
able to go up to it
and accomplish their
tasks really quickly.
They don't have to learn
how to use the interface.
You want them to achieve their
goals and get out of the way.
So learnability is incredibly
important in that scenario.
But if you're working
on, let's say,
a really complex enterprise
business system for customer
service management tools.
Then, the chances are that
they're more likely going
to invest more time in
learning how to use the system
and maybe there's
training involved.
So really the point is that
learnability in that case
is still important, but
other components of usability
may be a higher priority.
Efficiency is another
component of usability.
Once users have
learned the design,
how quickly can they
perform the tasks?
Efficiency is typically
measured by the number
of clicks or
keystrokes required,
or the total time on task.
But once again, it's important
to understand your users
and how they like to work.
For example, are they likely to
use the interface infrequently?
Or are they going to
be habitual users that
are in it every day--
maybe they're going to learn
hidden shortcuts and controls.
Keyboard shortcuts
can be extremely
efficient for the
proficient users.
But those that have to use the
interface a little bit less
often, if shortcuts are the
primary interaction tool,
they're going to be
really slowed down
by that because
they're not going
to understand what
those are and they're
going to have to learn them.
Memorability.
When users return to the design
after a period of not using it,
how easily can they
re-establish proficiency?
Think about how often
users will be coming back
to your product or service.
Obviously we all want them
to come every single day,
but chances are that they're
not going to do that.
Well, some people will,
but most often they won't.
For example, I have
diamond status on Delta,
but I don't go to the Delta
site every single day.
But when I do, it's
important that I
know where to find things.
I want them to be in the same
place that they were before.
So obviously, design
that's complicated
is going to make
it harder for users
to remember the exact steps
that they took to accomplish
the task, which is why
efficiency and memorability
actually go hand in hand.
If the design is more
efficient, then there
are going to be
less steps for them
to go through to
accomplish their tasks
and less things to remember.
This makes it easier for them
to reestablish proficiency, even
after a long period of not
having used the product.
So accessibility.
I think this one is
really important.
Can all users,
regardless of ability,
navigate, understand, and
achieve their goals equally,
without barriers?
In the words of Nicholas
Zachas, a friend
and engineer-- former friend and
engineer Yahoo, accessibility
is not a feature.
And I think that's
really important
to take into consideration.
This means that
accessibility is not
an optional item on a
list of product functions,
but instead a mandatory
requirement on par
with performance.
As such, every product
should be built
with accessibility in mind
from the very beginning.
While accessibility focuses
on people with disabilities,
many accessibility requirements
actually improve usability
for everybody.
So accessibility especially
benefits people that have--
that don't have disabilities,
but are in limiting situations.
So imagine that time I broke my
hand slamming it in a car door,
and I wasn't able to
use the device the way
that I normally would,
and I had to turn
on accessibility features
to be able to navigate.
Or even being outside
in the sunlight
with a phone, or a laptop,
where you're limited
by the contrast on the screen.
So, there are a lot
of things that we
call situational
disabilities that we
need to be thinking about when
we're designing our tools.
Errors.
How many errors do users
make, and how severe
are these errors?
And how easily can
they recover from them?
Errors are inevitable.
They happen.
Unintended actions happen.
Think about how many times
you're filling in a form.
Maybe you mistype
your email address,
put in the wrong password.
A lot of times, when I'm filling
out my credit card expiration
date, I put the wrong month in.
Then I get a big error, and I
have to go back and redo it.
But there's a difference between
these types of slips and user
interface problems.
If users continue to click on
a heading that's not actually
clickable, or they try to look
for something in the wrong part
of your navigation
system, then there's
probably something about the
design that we can improve.
One action is to take--
one action to take
is to make sure
all of the elements in
your UI are instrumented
for performance
metrics, so that you
can understand what
people are doing
when they use your product.
And if you don't
know what people
are doing, what
errors they're making,
you're not going to
be able to fix it.
So, a lot of times we just
look at performance metrics
for things that are
pretty standard.
But think about the elements
of your UI that you want,
you might not know that
people are clicking on,
but they are clicking on.
The non-clickable
things, like that header
that I talked about.
You might not instrument it,
because it's not a click.
But if people think it is,
you want to know that, too.
And finally satisfaction.
Satisfaction, I
consider is probably
the hardest to measure.
Satisfaction is
about how pleasant
is it to use your design.
Often, how often have
you been on a site, when
all of a sudden, you're
trying to accomplish a task,
all of a sudden this
satisfaction survey
pops up, like a weird thing that
kind of just jumps in your face
and interrupts your flow.
First of all, that's
not very satisfying.
But think about it.
People use that, businesses
use that because they
want to know what you think.
So we have to find ways
of asking our users what
they think without
being so annoying.
You can do this in
usability studies.
A lot of people will actually
use usability studies
as a way to gather that
qualitative information.
And that's great.
I love usability studies,
we do them all the time.
But sometimes we notice that
participants tend to rate
an interface highly on post-test
questionnaires even when they
fail to complete the task.
And the reason they
do that is for--
a couple of reasons.
One, the kind of
want to impress you.
They want, you
know, hey, I'm here.
I can really do this.
It's great.
You know, they don't want to
say anything negative to you.
Sometimes you're paying them
to participate in the study,
so they feel like they
have to please you.
But the worst one, the
one that makes me cringe,
is that they often
blame themselves.
That it wasn't the UI's problem,
it was my fault that I failed.
And so they don't want to show
that that was their fault.
They want to say,
everything was great.
It was wonderful.
It's not you it's me.
So unless they're carefully
worded, and another thing we
use is surveys.
But unless they are
carefully worded,
surveys can also result in
what we call acquiescence bias.
The fact that people
are more likely to agree
with a statement than
disagree with a statement.
So those satisfaction
surveys or those 4C surveys,
or whatever, you'll notice
that they are carefully
crafted so that they're
not biased or leading.
So it's hard, but
it's not impossible.
Good user researchers know
the proper methodologies
to use for measuring
satisfaction,
and I'll talk a little bit about
how we do that in a minute.
But now how we think
about usability,
the components of
which are learnability,
efficiency, memorability,
accessibility, errors,
and satisfaction, let me
share a little bit more
about our usability
philosophy at Google.
It's pretty simple--
focus on the user,
and all else will follow.
So how do we do that?
How do we focus on the user?
We do it by involving the
user in every phase of product
development.
When we think about the
phases of product development,
we typically think of a
temporal progression from idea
to launch.
Some of you may have
seen this framework
before, it's often referred
to as the double diamond.
During the discover
and planning phases,
we're trying to figure out what
the right thing is to build.
This phase is divergent
and exploratory.
It's a search for new
questions, before we
start to then synthesize
knowledge into an insight.
That's why we go wide
before we start to narrow.
In the remaining phases
of conceptual design,
detailed design,
and build, we're
focused on designing the right--
designing the thing right.
We take the insights that we
learned in the first phase,
and we explore
several solutions.
And then we narrow it down,
and craft the working solution
that we plan to bring to market.
This linear path helps us feel
like we're making progress.
But as you probably
already know,
if you've ever done
product development,
this is not how
things typically go.
This is what the process
looks like for real.
Yeah, this is more like it.
The reality is the
process is really messy.
You have an idea, you try
it out, you argue about it,
you mock it up.
Maybe you test it
out on a few users.
You realize that
they don't like it,
or there's something wrong with
it, so you try something else.
Then, maybe you
realize that there
are technical difficulties,
and the back end
can't support what you're
doing and makes it unfeasible.
So you have to loop back
somewhere near the beginning
and start again.
Somewhere in there
there's coffee and beer.
But your goals are
still the same.
You want to design
the right thing,
and design the thing right.
In other words, you want
it to address user needs,
and you want it to be usable.
So let's dive into
these phases and see
how you can keep the user at the
center of this messy process,
how you can focus on the user.
So during the
discovery phase, you
wanted to uncover opportunities
for design improvement.
If you have an existing product.
If you have a brand new product
that you're just working on,
you also want to start
looking at the market
and understanding the needs
that are out there that
aren't being fulfilled.
This phase should be a
really close partnership
between UX, engineering,
and product management.
But you should also involve
operations, support, marketing,
sales.
Any other specialists
in the organization
that talk to your users, so that
you can gather as much data as
possible about them.
The goal here is to
understand user needs,
understand who your users
are, and how they currently
use your product.
Quantitative research like
metrics and log analysis
really helps you
understand what of people
are doing, what
users are doing when
they're using your product.
But qualitative research, such
as ethnographic studies, which
is going out into the field
and actually observing users
in their natural environment.
Sounds like Dian
Fossey, but it is.
It's about going out there and
meeting them where they work,
seeing the environment
that they work in.
That helps you uncover
the why behind the what.
And sometimes the
why can surprise you.
So I'm going take a
little aside and tell you
a funny story that my
husband told me long ago.
He's a-- my husband's
a fiber optic engineer.
And there was a time when
a customer complained
about temporary outages
that were happening
around the same time each day.
And so he would look at
the data, and he would see,
yeah, there's a brief
outage, and it seems
to happen in the afternoon.
And they ran tests
and diagnostics
and they couldn't really figure
out why this was happening.
He sent technicians
out to the field
to look for those
usual suspects.
Apparently squirrels like
to gnaw on the wires,
and that can cause outages.
So they looked for little frays
and everything like that, they
couldn't find anything.
So he was becoming
really frustrated,
because he couldn't
figure out what was wrong.
So what he decided to do is
he sent the technician over
to the customer's site one day,
and he went out in the truck
with another technician,
and they just kind of went
around the area where
the outage was happening.
It's hard to pinpoint
exactly where it is.
And something happened.
He noticed a little
boy, about 10 years old,
walking home from school.
He had a stick in his hand.
And as they were walking, as
he was walking down the street,
he approaches what's
called a down guy.
And that's-- when you think
about a telephone pole,
and the way it
anchors to the ground.
That angular wire,
that's called a down guy.
He would take that stick as
he approached it and he would
give it a good thwack.
And what was happening was
that the vibration of the wire
was interrupting the light
path of the optical cable.
And so while it was vibrating
the outage happened, and then
it would stabilize and
the outage would stop.
So sure enough, moments after
the kid thwacks that line,
my husband gets a call.
Customer has an outage.
So he went to the
kid, and he was like,
do you do this every day?
The kid is like,
yeah, I like the sound
it makes when I hit it.
Because it does, it
makes this weird hum.
And he's like, oh my
god, we figured it out.
And so my point is that
there are some problems
that you'll never really
understand until you actually
go out in the field and
observe what people are doing.
So let me give you an example
of what I've experienced
on my own product in this area.
So in 2013, Hangouts
was a part of G+.
Through logs
analysis, we noticed
that it was becoming
increasingly
popular among business users.
So we reached out to
them to find out more.
We wanted to know why.
We conducted diary
studies and field research
with local businesses, and
based on what they told us
and what we observed,
we were able to uncover
some interesting
insights that lead
to opportunities to improve
the experience for them.
One thing we saw was
that there were basically
four types of meetings
where they used Hangouts.
The first is ad hoc.
These are your typical
pick up meetings.
These are the ones like, hey,
I have a really quick question.
Do you want to jump on
a Hangout and answer it?
Let's go into this quick room,
let me show you something.
Round tables are what we think
of as the more traditional,
typical meetings.
They are usually scheduled,
sometimes they're recurring.
Think about your team meetings,
or where you go into--
review something
or solve a problem.
Structured engagements are
more like sales presentations
or trainings.
This is where there's
usually one speaker
and he's presenting to a group.
And then spotlights, which
are generally larger meetings.
They're more like all-hands
and earning reports,
where you have one to many.
They're often broadcast to
a large audience that might
be remote or watching online.
Our customers are using Hangouts
on Air for things like that.
So once we got insight into why
and how Hangouts customers were
using the product, we
were able to conceive
of a new enterprised, focused
take on video meetings that
could better meet their needs.
So the second phase
of the design process
is-- the product development
process is planning.
This is about
clarifying and outlining
nuances of the problem.
The goals here are about
taking what you learned,
and deciding on the
right thing to build.
Some methods that you can
use to help you decide
are just prioritizing
the user problems,
or creating use
cases and scenarios
to help you understand when
somebody does something.
What are the scenarios
they're doing it in,
and what are they
trying to accomplish?
One thing that we
also do on my team
is what we call a strategy
brief, or a one pager.
And this is before the PRD.
This is when your first
sitting down and thinking
about the problem.
It doesn't get into
detail, but instead it
aligns the team on
the high level goals,
helps you identify
and narrow down
who it is that you're
trying to-- who is your user
and who it is that
you're trying to reach.
It also defines what
success looks like.
Because without
that North Star, you
can often like your
UX team, your PM team,
your engineers might all have
different and goals in mind,
and you might not be aligned.
So we found a
one-pager, very simple,
sit down and talk about
these things at a high level
and make sure you're
on the same page.
In the- and the last method
here is experience mapping,
and I'm going to
talk about that.
In my last example,
I mentioned that we
decided to focus on
the solving the user
needs of the common
roundtable meeting type
first, because that was
something that we felt
most of our users were doing.
But we didn't understand
what exactly they needed.
So to figure that
out, we decided
to create an experience
map of a typical meeting.
So what is an experience map?
This is pretty simplified.
But an experience map
is a strategic process
of capturing and communicating
interfaces or interactions
from a user's perspective.
In this example, I'm showing
a really simplified version
of the experience map
that we created when
developing our new product.
But what we structured
the map to do
is look at-- when you
think about meetings,
there are different
stages of meetings.
There's the before the
meeting, during the meeting,
and after the meeting.
And on the y-axis we have
what are users doing.
What are the tasks
that they're actually
doing during those phases?
What are they thinking while
they're doing those things?
How are they feeling
during those actions?
And then, what are
those opportunities
that the product can--
what do we see as opportunities
for solving some of those user
needs?
So, for example,
in the before phase
we found out that
business users were often
needing to take meetings
when they were on the road.
So, as you know,
internet connections
can be pretty spotty.
So under Opportunities
we decided
to put, provide dial-in
access to meetings,
so that they could
use their phone
rather than have
to rely on video.
So you can also add a section
for gaps, that's pretty common.
So you can look at
what the gaps are
in your product
versus the market.
But this is a really
helpful process
for just really laying out the
landscape of what your user is
doing and around your product.
Since meetings are spatial
as well as temporal,
we also have to consider a
variety of physical factors
when creating our map.
For example, before
a meeting begins,
you probably need
to find the room.
So what is the way--finding
system look like?
How confused are you going
to be about getting there?
How do you know how long it's
going to take you to get there?
And then when
you're in the room,
you need to use a remote to
actually start the meeting
and maybe control
some of the things,
like zooming and muting.
So there are a lot
of physical elements
that we had to
think about as well.
A lot of times the remote
goes missing in those rooms,
and then what do you do then?
So the activity of mapping an
experience like this really
helps organizations identify
strategic opportunities,
customer pain
points, and helps us
generate innovative products.
It also helps you
decide on where
to focus your energy before
moving to the conceptual design
phase.
So conceptual
design is where you
create the most apt
solution for the problem.
It's where you-- you're entering
this phase when you understand
what the problem is, but you
don't know yet how to solve it.
So from talking to our users
and creating the experience map,
we discovered that
joining a video meeting
can be a pretty painful
process, but we didn't really
know exactly how to solve that.
In this phase, our
goal is creativity.
We really want to
generate a lot of ideas.
No ideas are stupid
in this phase.
And then we start testing
and iterating on them.
We want to design
the thing right.
A great way to involve
the user in this phase
is to do rapid iterative
prototyping and quick usability
testing.
It doesn't have to
be on end users.
It can be with
people on your team,
it can be with the
sales department,
it can be with anybody nearby.
You really just want to
get ideas out there and try
and validate them as
quickly as possible
as to which is the one that
you want to move forward with.
My advice here is to
stay low fidelity.
And I'm talking sketches.
Wireframes.
Rough user flows.
This is about the idea,
not the execution.
The lower the fidelity,
the better, actually.
Even when testing with
users, paper prototypes
are really helpful.
We've learned that as the
fidelity of the wireframes
and prototypes goes up,
the quality of the feedback
actually can go down, because
people are hesitant to give you
negative feedback when they
think that you've actually
put a lot of effort into it.
So sometimes, even if we
work in high fidelity,
we will dumb it down.
We'll make it a little
bit less polished,
so when we put it
in front of people,
they feel a little bit more
comfortable in providing
feedback on the product.
So here's an example of what
we showed users early on.
As I mentioned for
video meetings,
it's critical that attendees
can join quickly and easily.
So we shared our ideas
for several different ways
that they could
set up a meeting.
So our options to
them were, hey, you
can have it be totally
open so anybody
with a link to the
meeting can join.
If someone is not invited or
outside the company's domain,
you can require them
to knock to get in.
Or you could choose to
completely lock it down,
so it's only open to people
who are on the calendar.
An invitation, no exceptions.
So we tested these
concepts, and people just
couldn't grasp all
the different options
and why they had
to make a choice.
How do I know
which one is right?
What if I'm wrong?
Why shouldn't I be able to
set it up one way and change
and the next time?
So we wrangled with
several text changes
to try and make
everything more clear.
But ultimately, we
decided to just come up
with a simple default, where if
you're not explicitly invited
to the meeting, you
can knock to get in.
We found that users expect
us to do the right thing.
And this was a
great moment when we
realized usability research
can influence the product
direction.
The detailed design
phase is where
you spec the complete
end-to-end solution.
So once we knew conceptually
where we wanted to go,
we entered this phase to
nail down the details.
This is about getting
the details right,
so your final product is
delightful and easy to use.
It's about holding a
high bar for quality,
and about making sure that
experience is consistent,
so users have to
relearn something
they maybe knew how to
do or should already
be familiar with.
An example that I
can pull from Google
is when you think about how
you share something in Docs,
Sheets, or Slides, you
know where that is,
and it always
behaves the same way.
So why reinvent the
wheel, especially if it's
part of a suite of products?
This is where the
designers on your team
are doing the visual polish
and the red lining-- or what
we call speccing out,
down to the pixel,
of how the UI should look
and behave for your engineers
to build.
This is also a phase
where you really
want to make sure your
accessibility spec is
up to date to determine how
screen readers are going to be
able to interpret your pages.
For our new video meeting
product, during this phase,
we also did an
extensive audit of what
we call critical user journeys.
And that's the last
method on here.
And I'll talk about
those right now.
So users don't think in
terms of single features.
They think in terms of
accomplishing tasks.
Tasks often involve
multiple features, products,
or product areas.
Thus they journey through the
hardware and the software.
Simply put, a user
journey is a task
that a user wants to perform,
and a critical user journey
is the really important journey
that you have to get right.
At Google, we identify two
types of critical user journeys.
Toothbrush journeys are what
we call the common tasks
that people perform often.
And pivotal journeys are
less frequent, but also
important tasks,
such as when you're
asking someone to sign in or use
the product for the first time.
They're not likely to
go through that again,
but you've got to get
it right the first time.
In my example, our journey
was as a first time user,
I want to join my next
meeting right now.
This journey forced us to take
a step back and think about what
it's like to experience our
product for the first time,
and acknowledge the
options for joining
could be a little
overwhelming and confusing.
Critical user journeys
frequently cross
product and feature
boundaries at a minimum--
at a minimum level,
you should be
aware of how what
you're working on
fits into the bigger picture.
With video meetings,
for example,
we had to think about how this
integrated into calendaring
and chat systems, so
that people could quickly
move from chat to video, or move
from a calendar into a video.
We wanted to make sure
the experience is going
to be excellent, for our
users, so we spent a full week
going through our
critical user journeys
and doing an audit to document
the potential pitfalls.
We scrutinized 30 journeys
just like this one,
and we looked at them
across all devices.
We looked at the iOS
and Android apps.
We looked at the TV experience,
when you're in a conference
room, we looked at the web.
We also looked at it through
a number of different lenses.
We had people looking
at the visual design
aspect, the interaction design,
the motion, the audio cues.
And accessibility.
And writing.
We even had our
writer take a look.
So every single person
was doing a pass
to make sure that
aspect of the experience
was the best that it could be.
We filed bugs even if a visual
design was a pixel or two off.
We were pretty strict.
So you can really do critical
user journeys at any time
during the design process.
Ideally, you want
to actually start
thinking about what those
critical user journeys are
early, so that you're part
of-- maybe when you're
doing your user
stories and scenarios.
But in our case, we had defined
them in the planning phase,
but we did the audit in
the detailed design phase,
before we were ready to
start going to launch.
And then finally
the build phase.
This is where we
implement, test,
and evaluate the solution.
The goals of the build phase are
about pride in craftsmanship.
Attention to detail.
Testing and launching.
And assessing the implementation
once it's launched.
As for the methods,
you want to make sure
that you've instrumented
the site using tools
like Google Analytics, or
whatever your preferred one is,
for performance and
usability metrics.
Remember, when we talked about
the components of usability
in the beginning, you
want to be confident
that you're capturing data
like number of clicks, errors,
and more.
You also want to run
experiments, such as A/B tests,
to see which design is
performing better for users.
But most importantly, you
want to engage in what
we call data informed design.
Not data driven design.
When you are data
driven, you're only
following the quantitative
results of your research.
The famous example at
Google is the 41 shades
of blue, when we
tested, literally,
41 shades of blue links
on the search page
to see which one
performed better.
You can look it up,
I'm not kidding.
And, that's great.
We saw actual,
different results when
we looked at all the
different shades of blue.
But that's a bit soulless.
It's not the way that we want
to think about using data
in our design process.
When you're data driven,
you only follow--
you're only looking
at the hard data,
but that data can
sometimes be misleading.
Because it will tell you
the what, but not the why.
And understanding
the why is where
you are able to take action.
Instead, use the
data and combine it
with qualitative feedback to
assess the complete picture.
This is data informed design.
Quantitative
metrics are also not
often useful for evaluating
the impact of the UX changes
that you make.
This is because
they're pretty general.
They don't usually
directly relate
to either the quality
of the user experience
or the goals of your
product, so it's
hard to make them actionable.
So to help with this, a few
smart researchers at Google
came up with a method
that we called HEART.
The HEART framework is
useful for evaluating
the quality of the
user experience
and the impact of UX
changes over time.
Happiness-- measures
user attitudes.
Often collected via those
surveys we talked about.
For example, satisfaction
surveys, perceived ease of use,
Net Promoter Score
is a good example.
Engagement-- measures the
level of user involvement.
Typically via
behavioral proxies,
such as frequency, intensity,
or depth of interaction
over some time period.
Examples might include the
number of visits per user
per week, or the
number of photos
uploaded per user per day.
For Hangouts, we want
to know how often people
are creating video meetings
and maybe how long has meetings
are.
Adoption measures the number
of new users of a product
or feature.
For example, you
want to-- in this one
you want to look at
the number of new users
that are creating accounts.
Maybe over a period
of time, like
accounts created
in last seven days,
or the percentage of new users
who create video meetings.
Retention is the rate
at which existing users
are returning to your product.
For example, how many of the
active users from a given time
period are still present
sometime later in the chat,
in the same time period?
You might be more interested
in failure to retain,
which is what we commonly known
as-- commonly known as churn.
And then Task Success includes
the traditional behavioral
metrics.
These include efficiency,
the time to complete a task,
effectiveness, the percent
of tasks completed.
And the error rate that
we discussed earlier.
This category is most applicable
to areas of your product
where they're very task
focused, such as doing a search
or upload flow.
So we're often asked why measure
adoption retention when you
can just count unique users?
It's definitely important
to count how many users you
had in a given time period.
For example, 70 actives.
But if you measure
adoption retention as well,
you're going to be explicitly
distinguishing new users
from returning users.
So you can tell how
quickly your user
base is growing or stabilizing.
This is especially useful
for new products and features
or those being redesigned.
Now, you don't necessarily
need to create metrics
in all these categories.
You should choose the ones
that are most important
for your particular project.
However, no matter what
type of metric you choose,
there's one important
principle that you always
want to stick to.
You want to ensure
that the metrics are
in line with the user goals that
you defined for your product.
So to wrap up, usability
is about keeping the user
at the center of your
product development process.
You want to consider the
learnability, the efficiency,
the memorability, the
accessibility, errors,
and satisfaction
inherent in your product.
I shared some of
the methods that we
use a Google, like experience
mapping and HEART metrics,
which I hope you found
useful and you can obviously
try in your own organizations.
We've touched at
very high levels
on some of these
methods, and so I
encourage you to look and
find resources on your own
in the web.
These are some of these
are fairly well known,
some of these are more
inherent to Google's culture.
But I really just hope that
if you learned one thing here
today, it's how important it is
to involve the user when you're
building products if you want
them to use them, and trust
them, and love them.
And since you're
all Google's users,
you can also be a part
of our design process.
So get involved.
If you're a GSuite administrator
or an end user of our tools,
you can sign up to be a part
of our GSuite user panel.
If you're a developer or
a cloud platform user,
you can sign up as well for our
Google cloud platform panel.
I'll leave this up
for a bit if you guys
want to take a snapshot.
I also want to use this time
to promote a session coming up
in the next room.
I think it's room number eight.
It's coming up right after this.
It's titled Driving Product
Excellence With User Feedback,
which will go deeper
into our research
practices and our trusted tester
and early adopter programs.
So if you want to learn more
about that, and the activities
that we do around
actually going on site
and talking to our customers.
That's a great session to go to.
Late last year we used
our trusted tester program
to validate key features
of our products,
such as supporting
larger meeting sizes,
and making it easier to join
meetings by phone or video.
These weren't just UX issues.
They were essential for
us to know whether we
had a product market fit.
We also invited several
particularly engaged
large customers to have
a seat at the table
during the design process.
We visited some of
those testers to watch
how the product
was used in action,
providing valuable insights
to improve our usability.
So thank you so much
for coming to Next
and coming to my session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]